thought of it the other day cuz my
friend goes N I got some Mexican guy to
do it is that good or is this bad and
then I realized I hired a Mexican guy to
do it can mean two different things you
walk in see Marty's backyard and go wow
Immaculate Caesar's Palace waterfall
yeah I got some Mexicans to do it like
damn they crush it or you can go
anywhere in skid row and go who built
this building and the owner going to go
I got some Mexicans to do
it how you say it I got some Mexicans to
do it I got some Mexicans to do it it's
either the best thing he ever did or the
worst thing he ever did America that's
you you let us
in he did he let us in now we're either
going to build a wall behind us or not
do [__] I'm talking about from
experience most Mexican fools my age in
the ghetto areas where I'm from they
have had one job for one summer Section
8 is popping welfare is flying let's
have another one even Mexicans go
[__] Mexicans dude